je me souviens d'une dissertation
d'économies le sujet était sur la dette
publique
c'était quand je préparais le concours
de l'ena à la tête d'un état qui est en
situation de faillite sur le plan
financier
dans la dernière partie de la
dissertation j'avais commencé en disant
que la piste j'avais commencé en disant
que la piste évidente pour réduire la
dette publique
c'était tout simplement de réduire les
dépenses dans l'absolu l'idée est simple
pertinente mais le prof m'a expliqué le
problème avec cette idée lorsqu'il m'a
rendu ma copie il m'a dit grosso modo
vous rendez compte que vous allez
probablement être corrigé par un haut
fonctionnaire dans la mission
quotidienne est de trouver des solutions
pour accroître les recettes pour faire
rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses de
l'état
et vous la première solution voulu
présenter c'est de réduire les dépenses
ça revient à lui dire qu'il fait
n'importe quoi you d'herman cain mais
c'est ce jour là que j'ai vraiment
compris
il faut se mettre à la place du
correcteur
je crois que comme moi lorsque j'étais
encore étudiant vous avez besoin d'une
petite piqûre de pragmatisme
vous avez tendance à l'oublier mais vos
dissertation ne sont pas corrigés par un
logiciel
alors certes pour certaines épreuves les
correcteurs suivant un barème
mais la dissertation ça ne sera jamais
comme les maths en définitive
l'évaluation comportera toujours une
bonne part de subjectivité moi qui
corrige en illimité toutes les copies
des membres de ma formation avancée à la
méthodologie de la dissertation
je peux vous le dire je fais tout mon
possible pour être juste mais il y a
plein de facteurs qui biaise mon
appréciation je suis parfois de mauvaise
humeur certains jours au contraire je
veux être gentil ou peut-être même
qu'aristote bien de faire une connerie
d'un côté je suis rodé parce que j'ai
corrigé beaucoup de copies depuis pas
mal d'années mais de l'autre côté je ne
serai jamais une machine c'est pour ça
que vous devez vous mettre à la place du
correcteur essayer de comprendre son
contexte de travail d'entrer dans sa
tête d'imaginer ses motivations ses
émotions etc
tout ça pour déterminer très précisément
ce qui lui plaît et qui va donc faire
gagner des points et ce qui lui déplaît
et qui va donc vous faire perdre des
ponts en tout cas une chose qui vous
fera gagner des points à tous les coups
c'est la méthode au enfin pas n'importe
quelle méthode aucune méthodologie
simple et efficace vous envoler une
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
et vous verrez qu'une fois que vous
aurez assimilé le court tout sera plus
clair dans votre esprit et vous
connaîtrez l'essentiel pour séduire le
correcteur comme c'est un cours par
email vous pourrez le découvrir après la
vidéo ou dans les prochains jours là
maintenant tout de suite préparez vous à
regarder attentivement cette vidéo parce
que je vais vous dire des choses que
vous n'entendrez pas dans une salle de
classe
regardez attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout et vous gagnerez plusieurs
points dès votre prochaine épreuve de
dissertation
vous croyez que ça ressemble à ça la
correction d'une dissertation
bon je pense que vous le savez le
correcteur a beaucoup de copies à
corriger
si les preuves dans une prépa ou à
l'université il a généralement plusieurs
classes donc il a un minimum 50 cents
copies à corriger en même temps si les
correcteurs pour un concours il a
jusqu'à plusieurs centaines de copies à
corriger
peut-être que vous ne réalisez pas ce
que la tâche représente donc faisons un
petit calcul
imaginons qu'un correcteur passent en
moyenne dix minutes sur chaque
dissertation ce qui est déjà rapide dix
minutes ça veut dire qu'il corrigera
seulement six copies en une heure
s'il a un paquet de 50 copies à corriger
ce qui est un petit paquet ça lui
prendra six heures comme la productivité
individuelle décroît avec la durée de la
tâche
c'est la loi des rendements décroissants
plus le paquet de copies est gros plus
le temps moyen de correction d'une seule
copie sera important donc je n'ai pas
calculé à la seconde près mais rendez
vous compte qu'à dix minutes par copie
un paquet de 100 copies ça représente
une dizaine d'heures de travail et un
paquet de 200 copies
ça représente une vingtaine voire une
trentaine d'heures de travail vous
rendez compte des dizaines d'heures de
travail
en plus au concours le correcteur est
payé à la copie on m'a dit 5 euros la
copie mais ça a peut être changé et puis
ça dépend probablement au des concours
et des années donc comme il est payé à
la copie est pas à l'heure il a intérêt
à corriger le plus de copie possible le
plus rapidement possible s'ils étaient
payés à l'heure en revanche il aurait
intérêt à prendre son temps la première
leçon qu'on peut tirer c'est donc que le
correcteur lire à votre dissertation a
rapidement voir très rapidement un
correcteur très consciencieux de
l'épreuve de dissertation de culture
générale du concours de l'ena m'a dit
qu'il prenait en moyenne entre 10 et 15
minutes par copie jeudi qu'il est très
consciencieux parce qu'il prend le temps
de lire le développement et même parfois
de vérifier les références des citations
sur internet mais il ya des correcteurs
moins consciencieux par exemple un
universitaire français bien connu et
auteur de manuels de référence ne pas
vous dire son nom est bien ce prof avoué
que son rythme de croisière lorsqu'il
corriger l'épreuve du concours d'entrée
de sciences po c'était une minute par
copie what the fuck is less une minute
par copie
mais ne lui en voulais pas parce que ça
ne veut pas dire que lui il bat que la
correction
ça veut simplement dire qu'il est
honnête lui les correcteurs à lise
rapidement voir très rapidement vos
dissertation c'est comme ça quelles sont
les conséquences pratiques pour vous
comment pouvez vous vous adaptez vous
pouvez le faire de trois manières
différentes
première adaptation mettez le paquet sur
l'introduction parce que comme le
correcteur n'a que peu de temps à vous
consacrer c'est l'introduction qu'il va
lire en priorité deuxième adaptation ne
vous prenez pas la tête ne perdez pas de
temps avec les détails
votre objectif c'est simplement de
produire une bonne impression pour une
lecture expéditive troisième adaptation
exprimez vous simplement sur le fond et
sur la forme parce que le correcteur
doit pouvoir vous comprendre très
facilement si vous suivez ses trois
conseils vous séduire et le correcteur
mais il ya encore des choses auxquelles
vous n'avez pas pensé
l'idiot par le romancier russe
dostoïevski
non mais je suis au courant que
dostoïevski est un roman cyrus pourquoi
est ce qu'il est inutile de préciser que
tu es l'auteur est un romancier telle
autre un philosophe de préciser leur
nationalité
ou encore comme je lis même dans de
bonnes copies de citer le titre d'un
livre en précisant que c'est un ouvrage
pourquoi ces précisions que sont l
inutile parce qu on écrit toujours pour
son lecteur
or votre lecteur c'est le correcteur et
le correcteur c'est un expert dans la
matière de votre dissertation
souvenez-vous de la croche de cette
vidéo qui corrige les dissertations
d'économie du concours d'entrée de l'ena
des énarques ce spécialiste des
questions économiques
et c'est pareil pour les autres matières
qui corrige les dissertation de
philosophie des profs de philo bad plus
30 ans fils aux passionnés de philo qui
pensent vive dorment philo des gens qui
lisent du monteil au petit déjeuner
comme je dis à mes élèves qui corrige
les dissertations de français des profs
de français bat de plus 30 en
littérature qui connaissent le
dictionnaire parker liste un livre par
jour et dont l'appartement est rempli de
livres
bon vous m'avez compris vous vous êtes
là et le correcteur il est là dans la
matière ou vous disserter c'est un
monstre un expert absolue
alors d'accord ce n'est pas toujours le
cas mais pour séduire le correcteur vous
avez intérêt à partir de l'idée que vous
êtes nulle par rapport à lui la leçon à
tirer de cette réalité c'est que vos
chances d'impressionner le correcteur
sont quasi nulles
oubliez donc cette ambition et essayez
simplement de prouver aux correcteurs
que vous êtes un bon voire un très bonne
élève
c'est bien plus facile et ça suffira
pour décrocher une super note
maintenant quelles sont les conséquences
pratiques pour vous comment pouvez vous
vous adaptez et bien c'est simple
n'essayez pas d'impressionner le
correcteur sur le fond c'est-à-dire ne
manipulez pas des idées compliqué
ensuite n'essayez pas non plus
d'impressionner le correcteur sur la
forme c'est à dire ne choisissez pas des
formulations travail est compliqué et
enfin n'essayez pas non plus
d'impressionner les correcteurs avec vos
références
c'est à dire n'essayez pas d'être
origine
al à tout prix parce que non seulement
ça ne marchera pas mais en plus vous
perdrez en pertinence et en cohérence
c'est à dire que vos références seront
mal adaptés à votre argumentation
et pour finir je vous rappelle la
première leçon le correcteur n'a pas le
temps de vous lire attentivement donc de
toute manière ça n'est pas du tout le
bon contexte pour essayer de
l'impressionner si vous vous mettez
vraiment à la place du correcteur vous
arrivez enfin à l'évidence il est un
être humain un être humain
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il
n'est pas un juge
objectif un juge parfait mais un être
humain avec ses failles
le correcteur a ses préférences ses
opinions ses préjugés ses faiblesses ses
forces et ses il ya peut-être des choses
qui le passionne et peut-être d'autres
auxquelles il est allergique
comment savoir c'est impossible
vous ne pouvez pas savoir comme vous et
moi il a ses problèmes et bien sûr que
ces problèmes l' influence dans la
notation
son quotidien est peut-être difficile il
est peut-être un peu dépressif il est
peut être pessimiste ou misanthrope
bien sûr il peut tout aussi bien être
heureux ou bien ni malheureux ni heureux
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce n'est
pas une machine qui va vous noté mais un
individu avec sa personnalité dans un
certain état émotionnel ma description
son état émotionnel était un peu noir
pour deux raisons tout d'abord parce que
prof c'est un métier plutôt mal
rémunérés et de moins en moins bien
considérés par rapport au niveau
d'études requis
ensuite parce que la correction des
copies c'est une corvée et ça l'est
encore plus lorsque le paquet est énorme
et qu'il faut le rendre avant une
certaine date limite
comme c'est le cas pour les correcteurs
des concours je vous rappelle qu'il
s'agit de lire à la suite des 10
zen voire des centaines de textes de
mauvaise qualité et ses textes portent
sur le même sujet le correcteur est donc
un être humain avec ses failles d'êtres
humains qui effectue une tâche pénible
vous croyez vraiment qu'il est un juge
impartial objectifs et tolérant plus tôt
non vous ne pouvez pas savoir mais mieux
vaut ne pas compter sur l'objectivité ou
sur la tolérance du correcteur c'est ça
la troisième et dernière le sont restés
prudents neutre avancer masqué comme dit
la célèbre devise de descartes la rva
tous pro deo
je sais bien qu'on vous recommande
parfois de prendre parti d'exprimer
votre personnalité mais si le correcteur
trouve votre opinion stupide si pas de
chance il est allergique à votre
personnalité vous croyez que ça va se
traduire comme ans dans la notation il
ne doit pas se dire au moins il est
original non il va se dire qu'est ce
qu'il est bête celui là l'est qu'on lui
en bref vous m'avez compris vous ne
savez pas qui est votre correcteur ne
prenez donc aucun risque
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en pratique
la première conséquence pratique pour
vous c'est que vous n'avez pas intérêt à
exprimer votre opinion au contraire
rester lisse et scolaire
tenez vous en aux idées conventionnelles
présenter vos arguments comme des
hypothèses et exprimez-vous avec nuance
la seconde conséquence pratique pour
vous ce que vous avez intérêt dans votre
dissertation a misé sur des qualités
universelle qui plairont à n'importe
quel correcteurs plutôt que de perdre
votre temps avec telles références telle
citation ou tel détail
apprenez et entraînez-vous à traiter
méthodiquement un sujet à organiser de
manière cohérente vos idées et à vous
exprimer clairement parce que tous les
correcteurs valorise la méthode la
cohérence et la clarté
qu'est ce que vous avez appris dans
cette vidéo
leçon numéro un le correcteur vous lira
rapidement voir très rapidement
donc vous devez soigner l'introduction
négliger les détails et vous exprimer
simplement
leçon numéro 2 le correcteur est un
expert dans la matière de votre
dissertation donc ça ne sert à rien
d'essayer de l'impressionner leçon
numéro 3 le correcteur n'est pas un juge
impartial donc vous devez avancer masqué
et surtout donner à votre dissertation
des qualités universel et donc
incontestable c'est justement l'esprit
dans lequel j'ai conçu mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation je vous donne une méthode
simple qui repose sur les qualités
fondamentales du discours si vous
appliquez cette méthode votre
dissertation plairont à tous les
correcteurs sans exception vous pouvez
recevoir mon cours de méthodologie
souhaite en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant aux audois de les
vidéos soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de cette vidéo
voila voila comme d'habitude j'espère
que cette vidéo vous sera utile je suis
romain je suis toujours avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sur 1000 et de
culture générale rappelez vous que vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour séduire le correcteur de votre
dissertation
[Musique]